So in case you haven't noticed,...
...work is a bit different these days.
It's not just jobs changing; the whole culture is different.
Everything from Ted, who's 24, and can't believe you'd actually want him...
...to fill out the whole status report,...
...to Jimbo, who's 35 and busy working anywhere but the office.
And Sharon, aged 50, who just might be the best juggler of all things...
...and most addicted one of the batch.
These days, things are moving at the speed of a tweet,...
...and people want access to company systems and data at all times.
Basically, our work styles have become as unique as our people.
Microsoft is here to help.
Check it out today at Microsoft.com.